Coffee drinkers are toasting a new study...
...linking a few cups a day to a longer life.
As medical reporter Emily Rice explains,...
...adding a little sugar doesn't hurt either.
Tiamo restaurant manager Julio won't reveal his age,...
...but will confirm he's been serving coffees in Melbourne cafes for 55 years.
He credits his boundless energy to a couple of cups or more per day.
A new study has found the popular brew may help you live longer.
After examining the consumption habits of 170,000 people in the UK,...
...researchers found regular coffee drinking...
...was associated with a 30% mortality reduction...
...and adding a teaspoon of sugar did not appear to reduce the benefits.
Cardiologist Professor Peter Kisler from the Baker Institute...
...conducted a similar study earlier this year...
...which found coffee drinkers had a lower risk of heart problems.
When it comes to the optimum dose of coffee,...
...it differs from person to person,...
...but like most things in life, moderation is key.